j'accueille maintenant martin fontaine
bonsoir c'est donc martin fontaine qui
est l on soit et à mogador ses panoramas
fontaine donc un spectacle que vous avez
déjà interprété 1500 fois et devant un
million de spectateurs car elvis story a
été créée il ya neuf ans au capitole de
québec
voilà vous êtes il choisit pourquoi
parce que franchement moi je vais vous
dire un truc je vous vois arriver dans
un casting pour faire un avis précis je
vous prends pas je sais on chercher
l'âme d'elvis donc pas nécessairement
l'image vont chercher un artiste qui
pouvait à la fois jeu et musiciens
chanteurs et excusez moi allez vous êtes
très bon elvis mais vous avez un accent
de merde
ouais je sais mais c'est pas mal mais il
faut vous entendre parler anglais 1 est
vraiment bon donc voilà donc on vous a
on vous a choisi parce que vous aviez
l'âme plutôt que le look web 1
c'est ça ouais ouais c'est vrai nom vous
avez un truc quand vous faites l'elvis
moi je les regardais tout à l'heure vous
avez ce truc c'est qu'ils relevé la
moitié de ça il relevé un petit peu ça
lève comme un motif
tout à fait ces exactions story d'adamo
justement pour trouver là mais c'est
vrai fait le coup de la lève pour voir h
peut pas l'egypte lui vous êtes plus
efficace at on alors le lancement en
france est assez important parce que
vous dites que effectivement si ce
spectacle a du succès en france ça peut
lui donner une envergure internationale
à le texte a été revu et corrigé par
christian blachas dessus humain est un
elvis au magnifique je trouve que ça
année le show à un autre niveau
en plus étant donné que christian et
journalistes et tout est un amoureux
d'elvis et je pense que ça c'est
vraiment le show vraiment un outil beaux
restes d'un spécialiste quand même
d'aider des réinterprétations parce que
vous aviez un groupe qui s'appelait de
wils ouais les quais renseigner au
toujours et qui faisait des reprises des
beatles et des stones
ouais moi je je pense que les beatles
m'ont vraiment tout appris au niveau
musical ils m'ont appris l'anglais
ils m'ont appris comment écrire des
chansons faire les arrangements musicaux
vocaux et tous et elvis pour moi
signifiait plus le showman que que juste
la musique alors tous les soirs dont il
ya deux heures de maquillage vous
transformer en elvis qu'est-ce qu'on
change bon les cheveux on a compris qu
est-ce qu on change tout on vous met des
gants il ya aucun rajout on n'utilise
que des ombres et lumières donc c'est
chez du maquillage de base fond de teint
bien on va regarder un petit peu on va
vous comparez à elvis presley en
regardant un extrait du spectacle à
mogador ça s'appelle elvis story